did you see that bitcoin is now
officially on the stock market
did you see that
what yeah yeah
not not bit bit bit bitcoin but bitcoin
let me break down what this means please
except bitcoin has hit the nysc yes hold
on a couple weeks ago where like bitcoin
is this cool kid having a party yeah it
was kind of cool now bank of america is
in there and now yeah oh you're legit oh
things have gotten more legit bitcoin is
prom king so bitcoin is now currently
worth 62
000
um as the time we're filming this i'm
sure it'll go down to 58 and then up to
65 and then down to 52 then up to 69
like it fluctuates but it's cross 60
it's hovering near all-time highs it's
up big this month certainly this week
for sure and part of that
young david is due to the enthusiasm
around the launch of the bitcoin futures
etf on the new york stock exchange okay
huge this is huge and i'll tell you why
not not so much
that that is huge
but what this means what's the meaning
behind this yeah this is this means that
crypto is now mainstream this means the
sec the securities exchange commission
right that the federal regulators the
people that are scrutinizing bitcoin are
saying
come to the party buddy yeah you're in
you're on board we're on board with you
hey buddy okay come sit with us so
basically
here's what's going on it's not bitcoin
itself not the 60 000 asset it's the
futures etf you can bet on the future of
bitcoin you're familiar with futures
contracts no we'll explain but i guess i
mean
just betting on it exactly so basically
the new york stock exchange is now
allowing
um traders to bet on bitcoin but again
not
directly on bitcoin that they will do
well or that it will sync exactly but
it's basically something called pro
shares etf that's the the company that's
responsible for this
that now within investors can basically
bet on what bitcoin is going to do
without actually having to hold on to
bitcoin right so the etf doesn't
actually own bitcoin you're just betting
on the future of bitcoin is it going up
or is it going down gambling straight up
gambling that's straight thank you thank
you that's exactly what it is that's
what futures
so we know what etfs are exchange traded
funds are basically
um they're a group of funds that that
basically track and assets i don't like
this okay sorry i just saw this going
down terrible
ways yeah we'll see
so this etf tracks bitcoin and then a
futures contract is basically a contract
to buy or sell an asset
at a future date at a future price okay
okay yeah yeah so
um
let's finish this up and we'll open up
some dialogue so basically this is the
first obviously the first bitcoin etf to
hit the the u.s regulated exchange
marketplace okay um and it's basically
been one of the top etf debuts ever
people have been trying to do this for
years and years and years i think in
2013
um
cameron and tyler winklevoss the wink of
all swims of facebook fame
they tried to launch an etf back then
didn't happen it's been years in the
making but here's what i can tell you
there's more coming buddy
there's a lot more coming oh i'm sure
this is just open up the floodgates yeah
dude but at the end of the day look this
is just gonna legitimize
bitcoin legitimize crypt i don't think
crypto's going through it i think
i think it's going to it it's
legitimized like you're already there
you already passed that what more do you
want
like what more do you do you want like
an actual [ __ ] coin like what more do
you want it is legitimized okay bank of
america is at the party bro yeah now the
party is at like the coolest kid's house
yeah like bitcoin is a winkle boss house
accept it he's part of the cool kids
but it is now okay go on if you haven't
but like couldn't this be just just
doesn't this make bitcoin even more
um
malleable like can't you just go ahead
and say if you're if
if you're betting like if you have
insider knowledge that [ __ ] tesla's
gonna or that elon musk is gonna sell
all his bitcoin mm-hmm you just bet on
that [ __ ] like this is just another way
to
make more money and manipulate bitcoin
because like for sure like when te i i
honestly believe that when tesla stopped
taking bitcoin it was so that the price
would go down so that they could buy
more and have more bitcoin
right like is that crazy to believe
well they i think at the time they
blamed it on the environment they didn't
understand yeah sure because you're an
environmental company and a solar energy
company and a green company electric
vehicle company but now all these
bitcoin miners are using a crazy amount
i can totally see a conference room
meeting we're like how do we do this uh
dude just say it is it's terrible for
the environment you know what else is
terrible for the environment airplanes
you think elon musk just [ __ ] drives
his tesla places he's on planes all the
[ __ ] times rocket ships he's got
rocket ships all right so do you think
this is a good or bad move for this
bitcoin etf no i think it's well it
depends on which side you're on and how
you look at it i mean obviously it's
like a milestone so let me ask you
three months from now bitcoin going to
be up or down from where it is now three
months from now so what we're q1 we're
january of 2022
uh bitcoin will be down they're gonna be
down yeah so you'll bet on the future of
bitcoin to be down yeah and if you
that's down you would win
you make some money so if it goes up
you gotta pay yeah that's the future
look i don't do futures i i like full
disclosure i'm not the futures guy i oh
i do own some bitcoin i do own some
crypto i i have invested an nft
platform i'm not the futures guy so i'm
not even gonna tell you the good the bad
the ugly the futures it's very
complicated it's not what i do
okay if you are gonna mess with futures
make it a very small percentage of your
portfolio yes you know what i like to do
with my money put it in index funds put
it in the stock market put in the s p
500 and let that money grow over time
and i take a small percentage i put that
in some crypto i'll put that some reits
i'll diversify but i'm not the the
futures guy either way i think it's a
very good thing for bitcoin i think it's
a very good thing for crypto overall it
gets people involved without having
actually owned bitcoin
legitimizes everything like you said
david smart young david bitcoin's at the
cool kids table now dude he's a and he's
at the coolest house
coolest house on the block yeah i just i
just see like someone like elon musk
that owns so much of it i'm sure um just
betting that it'll go down and then sell
all his [ __ ] and then he makes a bunch
of money this way then he can buy more
bitcoin at a cheaper price well that's
why it's like that's why they say
again
with the index fund target date funds
yeah long term if you have a long-term
perspective which we're going to talk
about in a story coming up
if you have a long-term perspective
you're going to win man yeah
term day to day week to week month to
month that's tough to do if you're
thinking a year down the road three
years down the road you know where you
want to be five years from now yeah i'm
not freaking out and selling today
because i've got a cushion and i've got
money saved up and i'm just gonna let
the rocky road of the bitcoin trail you
know go up and down but i know that it's
i believe in the asset class and it's
gonna be worth a hundred thousand one
day or five hundred thousand or one
million one day i'm not gonna freak out
when elon musk pumps and dumps yeah
i'm just gonna hold hold it's true
i'm not gonna do what these gen z kids
are doing and do drunk me
you
the boys
robin hood all we talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken